lifelong Republican : Powell former
Secretary of State Colin Powell retired
four-star general : Powell is slamming
Republican nominee Donald Trump as a
national disgrace and an international
pariah not on CNN not on PBS not on
right-wing radio this was actually not
even a recent comment it's a comment
that was recently uncovered because of
some leaked emails there's a website
called DC leaks comm which is reportedly
connected to Russian intelligence
services although it has not been
confirmed they have obtained a bunch of
: Powell's emails and on June 17th he
wrote an email to Emily Miller who's a
journalist who was once an aide to Colin
Powell and in that same email Powell
said Donald Trump is in the process of
destroying himself no need for Democrats
to attack him in an August 21st email
from Powell to Miller he blasted Donald
Trump for embarking on a racist movement
that believes President Obama was not
born in the US I have a quote to show
you from one of these emails to Emily
Miller this one on August 21st yep the
whole birther movement was racist that's
what the 99% believed when Trump
couldn't keep that up he said he also
wanted to see if the certificate noted
that he was a Muslim also saying as I
mentioned that Donald Trump is a
national disgrace : Powell was asked to
comment on this and this is just the
best
he told BuzzFeed news I have no further
comment I'm not denying it any time
Rachel that a politician says I'm not
denying X you can basically know for
sure that X is true because very often
the denials are lies so even even more
so when there is no denial that is that
is absolutely an admission from Colin
Powell that he said this stuff Oh
certainly I'm just wondering if there's
a certain double standard for him
because of all his comments about the
Iraq war and he was kind of painted as
this very negative type of figure and
now he's he has these comments about
Trump and everyone's kind of saying oh
actually this is wonderful he's taking a
stand even though it was from a leaked
email so it was never necessarily said
in a public forums I know there's such a
sort of I mean crisis is maybe an
exaggeration but there's sort of a
double standard of conscience for some
progressives on this on the one hand
we're talking about leaked emails right
this is not something that Colin Powell
intended to say although he opted not to
deny it but also : palette was one of
the main guys making the case to the
United Nations for the Iraq war based on
non-existent weapons of mass destruction
etc etc really really horrible and
depraved actions that we've been very
critical of : Powell for so then to say
hey everybody
even respectable longtime Republican :
Powell is slamming Trump and we should
really pay attention to that well we've
already sort of established that he was
willing to say things that were
absolutely atrocious and inaccurate and
not based in fact I think that the the
right perspective on this is not :
Powell is objectively a good guy so we
should believe him it's more that we're
talking about a lifelong Republican who
is so disgusted by the Republican
candidate that he feels this strongly
against Trump I don't know that
necessarily progressives has to take
tactic that this is one of the good
Republicans and thus what he says about
Trump means more I think what he says
about Trump merely based on his
political background is meaningful and
it doesn't in any way contradict that he
made absolutely horrible and inaccurate
comments about weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq I don't I don't know
that I'm on the of the mindset that by
even citing this guy you're saying that
he really did great stuff and and
anything other than these comments are
accurate